hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round two of the
affida grand prix semi-finals currently
being played in belgrade it's maxine
bashilagrav versus rihard rapport if
you've been following what's been
happening in the semifinals uh the first
game was won by robert it was an
incredible game where rapper pretty much
just crushed and wheeled with the white
pieces it was a very tricky game and
well that the groomfield
that we've discussed if you haven't seen
it do check it out uh you will
appreciate this one a lot more because
as he won the first game rapport only
needs to draw this game to go into the
finals and that means that you can
choose maybe not to go into some sort of
a crazy opening and you know just let
everything fly across the board
but that's kind of exactly what rapper
does here so it's an incredibly uh
difficult game to follow it's a very
long game so you guys better have
enough time to check it out so just to
make it a little more interesting i will
give you a super fun fact uh that was
posted on twitter uh by olympia urkan a
chess historian as we've had a
tartakover game a few videos ago with
that um a super end game that capablanca
played against artakover he said that
due to incredible research done by
michael lawrence we now know that
tartakover had green eyes and this uh up
until this point this was an unknown
fact so if you guys are you know going
out today or you will have a meet up
with your friends or family you can
impress them with your vast knowledge
about tartakov having green eyes it's a
fairly new information so i'm sure they
will appreciate it greatly now getting
back to the game envel has the white
pieces and he needs a win to force tie
breaks otherwise he's out of the
competition so here we have e4 uh and uh
e5 by rapport knight to f3 knights the
c6 and bishop to b5 so the royal lopez
is on the board and of course if you
need a draw you'll know what we play we
go for the berlin defense but here we
have a6 going for morphe's defense
bishop to a4 and now knight to f6 being
the most popular here rapper plays d6
and this is already leading uh into
something very very special that he
prepared maxine castles we have bishop
to g4 and of course h3 we challenged the
bishop and now the bishop has to move or
does does the bishop has to have to move
that's the question at upwards plays h5
and already this is only move six and
already rapport is offering a piece this
isn't really a peace offering because
the bishop cannot be captured here
if the bishop is captured then whatever
you do with the knight if you move it
queen comes to h4 and then you just get
checkmated so yeah you're not really
doing anything uh good here so we have
d4 this is the standard way of dealing
with the h5 idea and now also uh well
not the standard way the standard way is
actually to first eliminate the knight
and then after b captures uh then play
d4 and then okay we say okay now we're
threatening the captures on e5 we're
we're super fine with trading queens
then comes queen f6 and the game is uh
well very very interesting but here uh
maxime goes for the immediate d4 and now
rapper says all right since you didn't
capture here i will play b5 bishop to b3
and only now knight captures on d4 so
now you can see that there's a lot more
pressure the knight survived uh if black
is allowed to capture on f3 that's going
to be great for black so of course now
we play h captures on g4
but now it's a little bit different uh
because after h captures on g4 you are
controlling the g5 square as you've
pushed the pawn to d4so knights to g5
now you're already pressuring black
threatening to capture on f7 so knights
the h6 in the now how do you continue uh
one way is to play bishop to d5 put
pressure on the rook and then you don't
even care about c6 you can play c3 uh
push away the knight from d4 that will
be good good for you another way is to
just play f4 but this looks super
aggressive and as black prepared this it
might be a little a little dangerous for
example if g captures on f3 you can just
play knight captures on f3 and
everything is perfectly fine but still
you constantly have to keep an eye on
this h4 square so instead after this
knight h6 we have g3 by maxine and now
we have bishop to e7 just nicely
continuing development
we have f for now so not running away
from any
uh complications in fact maxine invites
complications because now uh if you go
for g captures on f3 we're going to play
knight captures on f3 and now let's say
queen d7 you want to go with the queen
to h3 there's king g2 and now
black and castle queen side and it's a
complete mess of a position so this is
something that maxine would definitely
like to avoid uh but uh yeah it's uh you
know it's something that has to be
played so here rapper doesn't go for
this he plays queen to d7 instead and
now we have f5 uh maximum closes this
and now there is no more attack on the
king side at least for the moment so
here c6 now you you can
maybe have some ideas of advancing d5 in
the future and now knight to c3 maxim
continues development we have queen to
d8 now putting pressure on the knight
here and here knight captures on f7 uh
so what's the idea behind this move well
knight captures on f7 and queen captures
on g4 going after the g7 pawn and it
seems that maxine is on the attack he
wants a win here but rapper says all
right let's just eliminate the bishop
here we have a captures on b3 and now we
have bishop to g5 uh
uh sorry bishop to g5 by black now uh
attacking the bishop on c1 we have king
to g2 and now queen to f6 so it's not
all that pleasant for the white king and
g2 but everything seems to be working
out nicely
here we have knight to d1 preparing to
bring the knight over to f2 maybe h3
then put a lot of pressure on this
bishop and basically force the trade so
rapper trades it right away
bishop captures on c1 rook captures on
c1 and now queen the g5 offering a queen
trade he says all right uh the
the the gambit paid off uh you didn't
really go for the most aggressive way of
playing it but now i trade queens and
well we call it a day so here in knight
to f2 you have to trade because your
rook is hanging on c1 as well so knight
to f2 queen captures and g for knight
captures and now knight to g5 going
after the d4 pawn
uh the e4 pawn and now knight back to f2
defending the pawn and now it's only
moved 23 the situation on the clock is
already maximum 27 minutes at upper 25
minutes and we still need to make uh 17
more moves to reach time control so here
rapper has a variety of moves to choose
from he can play king e7 king to d7 just
keep the king in the center of the board
which is something that
you can usually do you can start
advancing with a5 but he actually
castles queen sign with ideas of uh
busting through the center with the d5
and now he gives the white uh well sort
of a lot to play for because now uh
there's the open h file to go for
there's the the
a6 pawn that's a little bit weak uh d6
pawn is still a backwards spawn so here
you kind of give white uh some chances
and here maxine plays c4 first he wants
to keep the d6 pawn on d6 and keep it a
weakness we have king to c7 now comes
rook to h1 makes sense it's the only
open file on the board so we need to
place a rook on it
and now b captures on c4 again you could
try improving the position a little bit
further with king to b6 but the rocker
says this is fine b captures on c4 and
now a5 grabbing more space on the queen
side rook to a1 now we have pressure on
the queen side and on the king's side
and now king to b6 defending the spawn
we have rook h to d1 now still with full
control over the d5 square not allowing
black this d5 idea which is kind of the
whole reason why rapper played castle's
queen side he wanted to push a d5 so
here
we have rook to h7
and now comes a rook to d3 and this is a
beautiful rook lived by uh
by maxime uh there's the very aggressive
c5 check as you see if the if the pawn
is captured the rook here is hanging the
problem is after king captures on c5 you
can play rook captures on a5 and after
king to b6 there's even rook captures on
e5 so it seems like it's uh you know
kind of winning uh but then you run into
rook d to h8 and how are you how are you
playing this well we're going to play
rook captures on d6 now comes rook to h2
check king f1 and now you even allow
knight to f7 forking your rooks and once
the rook moves let's say rookie to e6
knight captures and e6 rook captures and
you have this position where white is up
two pawns and if anyone is better here
it's definitely white as the two rooks
really
are well uh hard to coordinate here with
the knight nicely covering the h1 square
so this would be playable for white uh
however maxime needs a win and he can't
just rush into something like this so
instead rook to d3 this move is more
precise we have rook d the h8 now going
for that attack on the king side and now
rook to b3 with check so we're winning
the a5 pawn regardless of what black
plays we have king to a6 now rook beat
the a3 going after the a5 pawn
rook to h2 with check king to f1 and now
king to b6 uh we have rook captures on
a5 and now comes knight to f3 and we
have this incredible position where
maxime is winning but only if he finds
the correct continuation and i had um
i had a lot of discussion with myself
which position to use in this game as
the pause the video moment because i had
like 20 to choose from and i decided to
use this one
because it's so early on in the game and
it's the one that really
makes all the difference so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
absolute best way for white to exploit
the advantage while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
pawn to c5 with check and now that you
see it of course as usual you believe it
as this will open up the d file to be
used for our rooks so here the captures
and c5 if you don't capture this you're
just getting checkmate it doesn't matter
what you do let's say you go king to b7
now all of the squares are taken away
from your rook a7 checking bait you're
going to go here king goes back and now
just rook to a7 will be checkmated the
b6 square is taken so the pawn
absolutely has to be captured we have d
captures on c5 and now rook to a6 with
check we have king to b5 interestingly
if you go king to c7 or king to b7 uh
it's playable but still very very ugly
king to b7 is definitely out of the
question because after rook to a7 check
king to b6 rook won the a6 check king b5
there's this very nasty rook a3 and now
this is hanging this is hanging uh but
not just that all of this is hanging
even if you play something like knights
to d4 then you run into rook b7 check
and where is the king gonna go the only
square is c4 and now rook to c3 is
checkmate as the d5 square is taken by
the white pawn so there are many many
things you want to do here this however
is not one of them another way you could
play this is to go king to c7 so this is
a little bit better as you have the d6
square but now we play rook a7 check
king d6 and we capture the g7 pawn and
now we have the f and the g pass pawns
that will start marching forward and
there is not all that much uh
black can do here uh for example if rook
h1 checked this is something that you
can play but after knight captures and
rook captures king to g2 attacks the
rook and the knight rook captures we
have king captures on f3 but still it's
uh only white who can win this the past
g and f pawn are simply too strong so
after rook to a6 we don't have king b7
or king c7 there's king to b5 and this
is a little bit uh different and even
more difficult to calculate
and maximum of course knows the uh the
way to do this he first plays rook 1 to
a5 with czech king to b4 uh if you go
king to c4 this is also possible then we
again go for rook to a3 attack the
knight and if knights to d4 then we play
rook to a7 and again there's this very
nasty
position where black has to be very very
careful not to get checkmated however
here you are up a tempo so you can waste
the move defending the spawn but still
knight the g4 will attack the rook and
after something like rook h1 king f2 and
now king to b4 so you don't get
checkmated there's still rook b7 check
and after knight to b5 there's knight
captures on e5 so incredibly complicated
position but the black is completely
tied down so instead after this uh we
don't have king to c4 king the b4 is
played and now uh rook to a for with
check of course maxim knows that rook to
a3 is the square for the rook that has
to be played because then you have all
of those tactics with the rook a3 rook
to c3 but this is move 36 and he needs a
few more moves to reach time control so
he's gonna give a few unnecessary checks
uh just to reach time control king to b5
rook 6 to 85 with cher king b6 rook a6
check king b5 rook 4 to a5 with check
king b4 and only now rook to a3 so now
this is mu 41 time control has been
reached and now you have additional time
to
you know try and win the game and did
not drop out of the semifinals so what
can a rapper do to defend here his
knight on f3 is hanging let's say he
goes knight to d4 yeah because knight to
d2 was played but knight to d4 is also
playable incredibly complicated so we
will show it uh here at knight six the
a4 will be played and after king b5
again rook to a7 and now going after the
g7 pawn and again if the pawn is
defended there's this rook v7 check you
have to go to c4 and rook to c3
checkmate so it's very very very hard to
play you don't have to
defend this pawn but still it's
incredibly incredibly ugly you have to
give it up that's the whole point of
black can play something like c4 uh just
to make some room for the king and c5
but it's going to be after king rook
captures on g7 it will be incredibly
difficult to defend this so instead of
knight to d4
like we said after this
rook to e3 move we have knight to d2
this comes with check and now maxime has
to make a choice one move wins the game
the other move does not win the game but
still you have to calculate a lot and
it's really impressive that maksim
played this incredibly quickly so here
you have to play king to g1 this is what
maksim played but just to give you an
idea of how difficult it is after king
to e1 black plays c4
and now after rook to a7 which is kind
of your whole point you you play knight
to b3 after rook captures and g7 now you
play rook to g2 this is the star move
that black has to defend the position
and now everything is well just
incredibly difficult to defend uh if
rook to b7 check we're gonna play king
to c5 and now uh what do you play here
uh you have to force a draw that's the
reality of the position because if you
try something like f6 then we just win
the game rook g1 check king e2 knight to
d4 check king to d2 and now rook to h2
going after the knight here and if you
try defending it uh king to e3 we just
play rook to e1 check for the king away
from the defense of the knight if you go
here attack the rook we first deliver
rook to e2 check now the knight falls
and of course black wins the game
so that's uh in case you try something
like f6 uh to try and win the game so
what you would actually have to do here
in order to not lose the game is just
giving up the rook here for the knight
and then after pawn captures you're
going to play rook captures on b3 and
now after rook h2 h2 you're going to
play rook to f3 defend your knight and
this is now a draw white is up two pawns
but also down the exchange some like
rogue g1 check king e2 rook to b1 can be
played but still it will yeah it will
not be enough for for anything serious j
even king to e3 now if you capture the
pawn for example then even knight the
knight to d3 check wins for white so
black has to be very very careful he'll
of course the
capturing of the pawn is not mandatory
you can continue checking rookie one
check and that's perfectly fine so
king the e1 is the way not to win the
game so of course maxine plays king the
g1 and now he's still winning so now uh
how can arapaho try and defend this he
tries knight to c4 if he can eliminate
the b2 pawn maybe then he can start
pushing his past c pawn as his g7 pawn
is still on the board so white still
can't push all that rapidly but maxim
again plays with the absolute precision
he plays rook to d3 and now the the idea
is uh let's say let's say black
characters on b2 uh rook the b6 check
and now after king to c4 you are trying
to give up uh this uh
this knight but the problem is uh we
don't uh capture the knight uh
if you capture here on b2 then rook
captures an f2 removes the defender of
the d3 rook so you've messed up your
position what you would have to do is
rook to a3 and now you've trapped the
knight there's no square here for the
knight and there's really not much uh
you can do here you're going to have to
play something like rook captures on f2
and after king captures now just to save
the knight knight to d1 check but again
king g2 knight to c3 and it's uh uh now
a terrible position for black white will
be able to win this easily uh so instead
after look to d3 uh we have rook two to
h6 now this is how uh rapper will try
and hold this he keeps an eye on his c6
pawn and now we have rook to a7 uh this
is one winning move uh the other one is
b3 but b3 is so complicated that we are
not going to go into that one uh so rook
to a7 this is also winning and perfectly
fine for maxime rook to b8 now
uh getting direct to that b file as we
always have to watch out for this rook
to b7 check and now uh now b3
this is uh playable but it it's not as
deadly as it was
when i first mentioned it because now we
have knight to a5 and upwards position
is now incredibly difficult to breach
unless you play one move and the maxim
finds the move which is uh which is just
incredible
and that is knight to g4
uh he attacks the rook here and now how
do you defend this
well uh knight captures on b3 that
rapper picks up the b3 pawn creates a
past c pawn and now he gives up the the
h6 rook however
maxine plays rook captures on g7 and
this is where maxime goes wrong you ha
you absolutely have to capture the the
rook here point is that it looks
dangerous because the c pawn will start
marching forward but uh you can stop at
c4 you're gonna play rook d6 and after g
captures on h6 you're going to play rook
captures on c6 and now once something
like knight to d4 is played uh it
doesn't matter because let's say rook
captures on h6 c3 you are uh just in
time to stop the pawn if king to b3 king
to g2 now allowing the rook to defend
the c1 square uh
this way and now if c2 we just play rook
h1 now both of the rooks are defending
the the c1 square now you start marching
your pawns forward and that's the way to
to win this position uh but um uh time
was not in abundance uh maxine played
rook captain g7 which again looks
incredibly winning for white uh but the
problem is uh it might not be so here c4
and now rook to d1 again if you try
knight captures an h6 here c captures
and d3 the pass pawn is now already on
d3 and it's not going to be possible to
stop it so after c4 we have rook to d1
and now rook h to h8 uh now how do you
defend this of course uh yeah here at
albert wants to keep an eye on his pawns
uh knight captures an e5 uh going after
the c6 pawn knight captures and c6 would
fork the rook and the king so rook h the
c8 defending this and now rook the g6
going after the c6 pawn once again and
uh rapper to just place c5 so here uh
believe it or not uh both players are
playing with with surgical precision uh
you know aside from that uh slip where
maxime did not capture the uh on h6 and
both players are now down to eight
minutes on the clock and that's after
they've reached time control so knight
to c6 check maxime grabs the exchange
rook captures on c6 rook captures and
now c3 the problem for maxime is now
that rapport um
well the only a counter player rapport
has is pushing the c pawn but that's the
only counter play he needs it's it's
impossible to stop the pawn with f6 by
maxim now comes c2 rook to f1 and c1
with queen
rook captures on c1 we have knight
captures on c1 and now uh e5 so now
maxime is down a full piece but his
pawns are well very very dangerous and
here we have knight to e2 with check
uh there are two ways to go about this
position with black uh of course if you
allow the the pawns to reach the seventh
rank then you just lost the game uh the
other one as it's a well it is just
super fun is rook to fate and this is
the actually the engine's favorite
choice but this is just something that
i'm showing you uh in order um
to demonstrate how uh well engines are
just engines and humans are just humans
because this is what the engine says
that you should play uh e6 rook captures
on f6 e7 now threatening to get a queen
knights to e2 with check king g2 and now
rook captures in c6 and after e8 queen
now uh knight to d4 defends everything
and of course the engine knows that this
is a draw however we are humans we are
most definitely not allowing our
opponent to
uh grab a queen into the game so instead
a rapper just goes for knight to the e
to check king f2 and now knight to d4
threatens the rook so everything has to
be with tempo otherwise the white ones
just start marching forward rook to d6
now comes knight to b5 if you defend the
knight with the king then you are also
blocking your pass pawn so it's better
just to move the knight and attack the
rook rook to d7 and now again arapat's
only plan is to push the other c pawn
but it works perfectly fine so c4
we have e6 by maxime c3 we have the e7
now comes c2 and f7 so the pawns are
both on the seventh rank and usually
this means that you've just won the game
however here uh it's a little bit
different c1 queen and now uh we have e8
queen the problem is if you play f8
queen it seems like you are threatening
to bring the other queen into the game
with check uh the problem is there's
queen c5 check and this now covers the
f8 square and it's the game over once
the king moves you give up the rook here
for the queen white brings another queen
into the game you capture on f8 and of
course completely winning so instead
after a c1 queen we have e8 queen it's a
little bit different but it also works
out very nicely for black here we have
queen to c5 with check and now
whatever white plays uh is is not enough
for for white to win because there's
simply too much coverage of the f8
square uh the problem is if you play
queen e3 you offer a queen trade then we
play queen to f5 check first and now
white has to block with the queen
because uh the rook hangs and after
queen f4 you simply trade captures
captures and play king to c5 you have a
f8 squid f8 square covered knight is
coming here uh you're gonna put the rook
on f sorry knight is coming here you're
going to put the rook on f8 you're going
to win the f7 pawn that's game so
instead after queen c5 check uh maxime
tries king to g2 but now comes a queen
to c6 with check not a not an easy move
to find but uh rapport spots the
perpetual king the h3 and now queen to
h6 with check we have king to g2
and it was in this position on move 66
uh that maxima shilograph and the
richard rapport agreed to a draw as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
you're just going to have to repeat and
then black goes back or if you persist
for example after king g2 let's say
queen to c6 checking h3 you go queen h6
check if white persists with king to g4
trying something then even queen g6
check and now you have coverage of the
eight square that's a game now king h3
we're going to play queen to h5 check
king g2 and rook chapter 78 so perfectly
fine for black captures captures and now
of course black is completely winning so
an incredible game where uh rapport
chose this very very tricky line with um
very early on uh as early as the move uh
uh as move nine with this uh
sorry as as early as move six with this
h3h5 idea so he was not playing for a
draw he wanted a sharper game he wanted
a game where you know he plays that
where he is the strongest and that is
super complicated positions uh he got a
complicated position then it all calmed
down but he then persisted and continued
uh to you know just a complicated with
that queen side castle and going for
that d5 square uh and indian the maxim
got a winning position he founded the
brilliancy with c5 as i imagine most of
you have in this here position so c5
very important in opening up the d file
for the for the white rooks but in the
end where it mattered most where he had
to capture here on h6
he simply did not do it he played rook
captures on g7 and that was uh enough
for rapper to to claim a draw sometimes
the move that you know anyone would play
you put this position on the board in
the middle of the street and you know
whoever passes by they're gonna play oh
there's a there's a rook hanging so uh
sometimes it's that simple but uh
uh you know maxim of course uh did not
capture it for for good reasons uh it
was too too much to calculate and they
were all uh incredibly tired the game
lasted for like five hours and this was
already
four and a half hours of play so of
course no one can blame anyone uh but
this would mean that uh maxime is out of
the semifinals and that up or reaches
the finals of defeating grand prix in
belgrade where he is waiting for the
winner of the match anish giri and
uh anishigiri and uh uh on
uh andreikin and we're gonna see that
one after as they've drawn both of their
classical games they have to play it now
rapid tie breaks to see who will face
rapport in the finals
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it and that you've learned
you know something a little bit just
because you need a draw doesn't mean you
have to play a boring berlin you have to
play something where you are strongest
and then you will either win or draw the
game uh or you know sometimes lose but
you have to play that which suits you
best and not just try something because
you know uh it it's generally accepted
that you should do that
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that a little bit of
trivia in the beginning about tartakover
having green eyes so hope that was uh to
your liking as well uh i would like to
thank lucas de ocaries jonathan lay dave
austin morona saxateel is a better serve
caster than bob the garbage man and uh
philippe velkovsky for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the grand
prix until it finishes so thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day